on ne retraitent procès va durer
cette fois ils avaient décidé de
s'inviter à un péage d'autoroute
pour ces manifestants jurassien
majoritairement issus de la cgt il
fallait ce week-end encore maintenir la
pression
on ne lâchera rien ni aujourd'hui ni
demain il me semble que dans le passé
les gens qui s'appelait fillon et juppé
le hall h et la résistance est à dix
grévistes les syndicalistes qui
lâcheront que le peuple à mort de ces en
a marre de cette politique cette
politique d'austérité qui nuit quand
même à toute personne qui aujourd'hui
voudraient vivre dignement dignement de
son travail
certains automobilistes ont pu passer
graphiquement la barrière de péage
mais pour ces militants syndicaux
l'objectif était avant tout de
distribuer des tracts sur la réforme des
retraites
parmi eux des cheminots qui ont cessé le
travail il y a des semaines ça fait
combien de jours vous attendrez vous ça
fait 22 jours maintenant ça devient
quand même assez compliqué on essaye de
rester soudés d'être toujours dans le
mouvement aux côtés des gilets de la cgt
quelques gilet jaune de dole qui semaine
après semaine continue à battre le pavé
moi je suis gilet jaune depuis le 8
décembre 2018 où on a commencé à dole
les premiers en france
et oui la retraite est importante mais
il faut aussi qu'on relance le mouvement
pour les autres choses qui un jour après
jour sont en train de nous passer en
dessous les jambes
voilà en fin de matinée les manifestants
ont quitté le péage pour s'installer un
peu plus loin sur un rond point
il n'y a pas eu d'incidents malgré
quelques ralentissements
les forces de l'ordre elles sont restées
discrètes